Speaker 1: Let's go next to
Speaker 2: Aiden
Speaker 1: in Cleveland. Aiden, you're on the air.
Hello, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: So. At the moment,
I'm kind of just very confused about the
situation in Ukraine. OK. Like many others,
I've seen on different news sources how there's
the convoy heading to Kiev bombings throughout the
country. Yeah, and just in. Knowing all of that,
I'm kind of confused as to why there hasn't been
any military intervention from Naito or
anyone else, and I'm not saying that I
support that. I understood I also believe
that we should just let Russia take over
the country and do as they please.
Speaker 1: I totally understand what
you're saying. My understanding and
things are changing so quickly that
by the time this clip is published, things
may have changed. My understanding is that
there is still this idea of keeping some gas
in the tank, so to speak, keeping more things
that you can do if Putin escalates further. Now
you're bringing up a good question, which is like,
what is there? What escalation is there beyond
literally trying to take the capital of Ukraine?
Right. It's a it's a totally fair question. I
don't know. I don't know the exact calculus, but
I think the principle that's at play is leaving
things that you can still do. And it's not clear
to me. I mean, listen, Ukraine is not a narrow
country, so I think that NATO's to send troops
probably needs to be able to more directly
justify that at this point. The invasion is
actually encroaching on NATO's country borders.
That may be something that is a milestone that
they're waiting for, but we don't really know
the answer. We're just kind of thinking out loud.
Speaker 2: OK, thank you. I just wanted your
Speaker 1: input in that. Yeah,
that's my best assessment right now,
and we don't have full information.
Thank you. My pleasure, thank you so much.